this is from Aviation week Network okay
so they got the scoop while all of us
are spinning around in circles being
like UFOs what's going on Joe Biden's
freaking out they're just deploying f22s
they're shooting down unidentified
flying objects and here's my favorite
part the pilot said it had no observable
propulsion system because
but that I swear you watch my segment I
said when they say there's no propulsion
system it could be because it's a
balloon like there's not going to be a
jet on a balloon or anything like that
so they see this big object and like I
wonder how it's flying and they shoot it
down so here's the story hobby club's
missing balloon feared shot down I'll
give you the gist of it the general idea
is the Northern Illinois bottle cap
balloon Brigade nib is not pointing
fingers yet but the circumstantial
evidence is at least intriguing the
club's silver coated party style Pico
balloon reported its last position on
February 10th at 38 910 feet off the
west coast of Alaska and a popular
forecasting tool the his split model
provided by Noah projected the
cylindrically shaped object would be
floating higher the central part of the
Yukon Territory on February 11th that's
the same day a Lockheed Martin F-22 shot
down unidentified object of a similar
description and altitude in the same
general area
okay I'm sorry China's laughing at us
right now yeah I I think it's cool
though that there's hobby balloon clubs
this balloon apparently was on its
seventh trip around the world so that's
kind of cool for the balloon it's a
shame that it's not there it is absurd
though that we used our height perhaps
perhaps we used our highest uh our
highest Air Force tools to shoot down a
balloon well I mean look everybody was
ragging on Biden over the Chinese
balloon so they started panicking now
then they started saying we think these
could these these objects could be
anything from like used car balloons or
whatever and it's just like oh man Biden
also said today uh at a press conference
he said um that he has no regrets about
shooting down the balloon of course he
doesn't spending four hundred thousand
dollars around a hobby balloon doesn't
make any sense is that how much the
missiles cost I think that's what I read
as a uh uh whatever
half a million dollars because they
panicked over this balloon we are we
three of them three three balloons we
are silly people well how big are these
balloons like that doesn't look like
that big of a balloon no that's a
plastic bag they said it's like three
three cars or something like that that's
a Pico balloon that's what that is
that's a Pico balloon that's actually it
that's a Pico balloon yeah the first
thing was the three school buses yeah
the way they go the thing they didn't
shoot down right away the actual this is
the threat right here I want you to to
look at this this dastardly group look
at this this woman this this girl's
wearing a suit
in a comedy movie where it shows like
the dejected hobbyists after that gets
shot down and they're all like real sad
about it I'm picturing like those guys
in the the um the X-Files you know the
three guys the reasons oh what was it uh
yeah yeah yeah I'm imagining those guys
yeah that kind of like disappoint me
yeah exactly the lone gunman so what now
do our tax dollars have to pay these
well we probably should pay them back
for their for their balloon I mean so so
what it's going to cost is half a
million dollars 500 and 1 000 now this
this blunder by Joe Biden should cover
the card what I want to know is there
was the other one where the pilot
actually missed on the first show that's
right million dollars
was that the same type of balloon though
was that a real balloon yo could you
just imagine they're seeing this silver
cylinder and it's just a balloon and
they're like ah when the missile misses
miss miss and they're like taking it
very seriously yeah we are silly people
do you think this could be military
exercise though too like I would have
thought okay if we were going to do this
type of stuff we like they would have at
least come out and tell us that like you
know maybe we're preparing for China to
send an EMP or something over but then
you know it would cause issues if and so
they it went with this alien theme but I
could see them trying to lie because
usually the LIE is better than the than
the than the truth they were they were
they were doing something over DC the
other day I guess everybody was freaking
out about that well remember like back
in like 2014 or something when the 82nd
jumped into Texas and everybody thought
that the federal government was invading
Texas oh it's kind of the same type of
stuff there was this thing that happened
a few years ago where a bunch of people
started on Twitter started posting
photos of military vehicles and videos
of uh trains transporting tanks and they
all started saying like whoa what's
happening everybody was in on it and
then journalists started seeing all
these videos and thinking something was
really happening started actually
writing out writing up stories about
this and and it was nothing they're
going to the gym they're going to jrtc
or something for well no no it was like
people people took random images so they
take a random image of a field with a
guy standing and they'd be like whoa New
Image out of this city or whatever I'm
like whoa now we're hearing that the
police are showing up and puts a picture
of a squad car and then someone like the
military is being brought in and you see
helicopters and they're all just
different random videos from different
time periods but people were claiming
were from oh my goodness yeah that's
like that's like that uh evelynwa novel
scoop where all the journalists get sent
to the war zone and you know the main
character gets there and there's no war
there's just no war at all well this is
like all the dogs yeah yeah or in Wag
the Dog while they're like oh we're
gonna have a war with Albania for to to
cover up that the president slept with
the Firefly girl I I was you know look
the other day I was pretty scared about
the AI stuff you know and I'm like oh
man and then just before this show I saw
one of the best AI deep fakes I've ever
seen and and I started and now I'm
really excited because it wasn't Donald
Trump and Joe Biden playing OverWatch
together oh my goodness is that
available I want to watch that yeah it's
on political Compass memes on Instagram
I should pull it up I don't know if I
can pull it up because it's gonna let me
see if I can get it uh and there's a lot
of swearing in it so just you know but
it's too good it's it was too good uh
there's a lot of swearing in it so let
me see if I can get it we were talking
about this at a meeting earlier uh this
is oh there it is there it is all right
you know where you're you avert your it
cover your your kids ears because we're
playing this I was playing OverWatch I
like OverWatch though
hold on we got to fix the audio yo this
is awesome I I love deep fake now I love
this map takes me back is that you again
Joe on my team it's this guy oh
GG we lost this is my rank up game too
we are not even out of Spawn doors and
this guy is already complaining someone
dodged please
again and you're gonna feed again how
many accounts do I have to keep
avoiding you are not beating the hard
stuck Masters allegations Don that is so
cap Joe
really good day today I don't care if
golfing hit a few holes in one don't
want to solo queue some OverWatch to end
the day and I see
bidenator
I can't wait until next matchmaking
Jesus quick yeah that was the
best that's the reality we need I saw
that like right as we're getting ready
to do the show when did they post this
they posted an hour ago it's like Kang
and konos yeah from The Simpsons I mean
this is one way politically I was
golfing I wanted to end the day with
some quick cues and OverWatch and then I
see bidenator in my chat we were saying
today at a meeting earlier
um our development meeting one of one of
the devs Tony was saying like what we
really need is to see a deep fake that's
terrifying that where where everyone
like basically realizes the horror that
this could reek on us like someone I
mean just something where everyone but
not that we need to do that to people
but I think in order for us to realize
how dangerous this is this technology so
yourself what would be the most
horrifying deep fake well so so War of
the Worlds kind of freak people out that
Orson Welles think people thought we
were really being invaded by aliens sure
I disagree uh the the typical mistake
people make with with PR campaigns and
things like this is that they think
shock content Alien Invasion World War
III people won't believe it it's too out
of the ordinary it's got to be something
very simple like Joe Biden giving a
speech and saying something like it's
got to be in order to get people to
understand it's scary and actually get
them to believe it it's got to be
something about maybe a banking crisis
or like a city's been wiped off the map
no one will believe Nuclear Strike no
one will believe it what about people
are going to be like what and they're
gonna try and look it up but if it's a
video of Joe Biden saying something like
we're growing deeply concerned with the
rising inflation rates which are now
expected to reach 11 by the next month
but the Federal Reserve has has given us
their word they will they will lower the
rates and try and get these inflation
rates down people will then start
freaking out if Biden says something
like we are worried but please remain
calm that the cost of basic Goods could
reach upwards of 10 to 20 dollars for
things like a gallon of milk that's the
kind of thing that people would see and
be like it would freak out the average
middle class person be believable enough
to where they go wait a minute that was
fake holy crap I know that would
definitely wreck the account it could
potentially wreck of the economy for a
day like people will sell stocks could
destroy the stock market but right to
really scare people I don't know if that
would really say I think the well I
think the scariest stuff is actually the
revenge porn stuff that's happening in
the Deep fake porn that's putting
people's bodies into these films that
they didn't consent oh like a porn of
Joe Biden that would be really scary all
right I disagree look like that stuff
exists you know it's not you and it's
not real I don't know I can understand
it's shocking to people to have that
happen to them for sure but I see what
you're saying about it being something
super normal like something that could
definitely be real which is in fact not
real yeah exactly I mean so it's like so
it's like a magic if you imagine that
like they're the um the information
that's been coming out over the past
year when things like bacon and milk
have gone up and eggs have gone up and
all of that and it sort of gets ignored
by a lot of the press but something like
that those things really do have an
impact on people that would be
interesting or what if he was you know
what if Biden makes the announcement
that we're definitely going to be
sending troops into Ukraine yes I was
going to say and if it's believable but
terrible it's very believable and then
you'd have everybody being like you know
it was only in what was it March when
Biden said there will be no troops on
the ground he said that very
definitively he also said there'd be no
tanks he also said there'd be no fighter
jets what's next and that would that
would set off an international Firestorm
if if there was a video where it's Biden
giving a speech
and he said something like
Russian Artillery has struck the border
of Poland
triggering Article Five right I as the
President of the United States states
I'm left with no choice but to deploy
U.S forces to assist our partners in
nato in the war effort against Russia
make no mistake by the time the American
people we are at War yeah
you can't go too much like if he said
Russia nuked a city or something people
would be like I'll just check it what if
he's saying freak out okay we already
know that there was the reporting that a
missile hit Poland right and everyone
freaked out
turns out it was Ukrainian artillery
that misfired or whatever right crashed
so it's that that's the mid-range level
where people will start panicking the
economy will get disrupted to a certain
degree and then they'll have to come out
and the White House would have to issue
a statement saying it's not true but
even then you're gonna have people being
like I've got two videos which one's
real that's the scariest one no and then
what and then the impact on
International leaders
yeah I mean at that same point in time
it would come out and Putin might be
like oh now I'm gonna preemptively
strike yeah I know that's in the nuke
preemptively and that and you're right
it does play into your that is probably
the scariest scenario that you could
have because it is believable and it it
plays into your your it has to be on the
border of unbelievable yeah where it's
terrifying and may be true like a meteor
coming towards Earth or something that's
completely unbelievable nobody would
believe it
if it was coming out of Biden's mouth
you don't think half the country sorry
where they blow up asteroids right if if
I didn't
of Biden saying a meteor is coming and
it's going to destroy the Earth or slam
into a city and wipe it out people are
gonna go what what is this and they're
going to go to Google right away and say
it's fake and it's going to say don't
look up but if it's a video of Biden
saying something like a Russian
Artillery strike we believe uh has has
struck polish territory triggering
Article Five Poland has requested that
the U.S deploy assets immediately to the
area for defense people are going to see
that and go dude dude they're going to
share with their friends and they're
gonna back look at this video look at
this video because it's believable in
the Russian cabinet we'll be sharing it
amongst themselves and that's where it
becomes really scary is do the does the
opposing party also believe it or
trigger a war which I don't want that to
happen does the Russian military say
you know President Putin this deep fake
is going around claiming that you know
Russian Artillery hit and that the us is
going to be deploying troops I say we
pretend we think it's real and deploy
troops and use this as a Casa's belly
yeah
wow
or or or sorry sorry someone can make a
video of Vladimir Putin playing
OverWatch with Biden X for sure
definitely Canyon konos we were trying
to figure out how to how to prevent this
deep fake confusion earlier in what
another one of the developers Alex was
like you need to Watermark your your
videos when they go up from now on like
the future is kind of like locking your
door at night you can't expect the
government to lock your door for you you
can't expect other people to know if
your video is real or not or if it's a
deep fake of you so you've got to
somehow prove it
uh but then I'm like what about fair use
like how did they prove that it's well
some developers will use like certain
stuff I was reading an article before
where it's in like movies and
documentaries where they did like the
whole documentary and whenever it was
like the AI generated they would put
like a halo around the person that they
were AI generating so the audience
subtly knew but then then the
conversation was do we then
you know that that pulls you out of this
immersive experience that you're going
to do so what's the trade-off of of
having you know in a movie or something
like that where you're deep faking it's
there's a trade-off there somewhere
someone chatted super chatted uh that's
um because reasons that deep fakes won't
exist in five years you'll just be able
it's going so quickly you'll be able to
make any kind of content you want but
that's literally deep fakes dude if
you're you're saying like you can just
tell it to make whatever you want we
already talked about this a couple weeks
ago there's a there's an ad I saw on
Twitter
for an AI video generating service
meaning it's an editing software and
you'll type in slowpan in forest at
night and then it renders and then gives
you a video showing trees and the
cameras panning through a forest it's
crazy it's like when chat GPT was
writing stories but video video which is
even now imagine once it can do people
and and VOC and voices all in one and
you just type in give me a video of an
action a Superhero fighting a super
villain in a city and then it renders it
and gives you a 30 second clip you could
then be like make a video of Joe Biden
declaring war on Russia and it would be
indistinguishable from The Real World
well and then when you combine that with
VR suddenly no one has to
exist in reality ever again so say will
we ever will we ever have movies or
anything like that again because you can
generate movies just digitally yes but
it what I think it'll be like is there
will be user generated movies and people
are going to say oh dude did you see
that new movie from Ian it's really good
go to his profile he's got a patreon he
makes movies and you'll literally just
you write out the treatment for a script
AI generate it go in and find fine tune
some of the points in the movie that you
think aren't that good about a week's
worth of work and you've got a full
length Marvel dude movie there could be
humans that with a neural net go into a
hyperbaric chamber and all they do is
think about movies that are constantly
being created for the public and all
they're just like in a in a cocoon where
they're just generating thought the
precogs wow they'll strap themselves in
and predict the future for us
yeah what were we talking about we're
talking about Joe Biden shooting
it might be another thing I think that
should be the first AI generated film
should be the three kids balloon no no
the first one should be the people who
are creating the AI generated films it
should be like super meta oh like a
movie about how they became the ones
that created yeah yeah but at the end
you find out they created the movie that
you're watching about them creating the
movie yeah like that I think the balloon
is a distraction I got this one because
I still haven't heard Biden mention East
Palestine have you guys heard him
mention it yet no but FEMA denied claims
for emergency relief because people's
homes weren't destroyed by the toxic
chemicals thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time